Tiens ! Une carte postale !
C'est Bruno Maltor !
Alors, où est-ce qu'il est cette fois-ci ?
L'île Maurice !
Le petit veinard.
Les plages de sable fin,
l'océan Indien à perte de vue.
Ça donne envie, hein.
Allez, aujourd'hui, avec Bruno,
je vous emmène découvrir des paysages
tous plus fous les uns que les autres.
Les impressionnantes chutes du parc
des Gorges de la rivière Noire,
la cascade sous marine de Morne Brabant
ou encore les décors féériques
de la mythique Terre des sept couleurs.
Allez, c'est parti !
Direction l'océan Indien.
Vous voyez ce petit confetti
dans l'océan Indien ?
C'est l'île Maurice, elle se situe à plus
de 9400 km de Paris à vol d'oiseau.
Et c'est ici que se trouve Bruno.
Salut Bruno.
Bienvenue dans l'aventure Épicurieux.
Salut Jamy, salut à tous ! Depuis un cadre assez paradisiaque,
je suis ravi d'être avec vous aujourd'hui.
Je suis très content également.
Je te présente rapidement
pour ceux qui ne se connaissent pas.
Il y en a peu.
Tu es blogueur voyage depuis dix ans,
tu as parcouru des dizaines de pays.
Bref, tu es l'expert de terrain qu'il
nous faut pour découvrir l'île Maurice.
Bonne présentation.
Merci beaucoup.
Et oui, c'est clair que des richesses,
l'île n'en manque pas.
Vous allez voir.
D'ailleurs, je vais mettre en route tout de suite
parce qu'il y a de quoi faire par ici.
Cette île est au centre
de l'archipel des Mascareignes,
avec l'île de la Réunion
à l'ouest, et Rodrigues à l'est.
Avec Bruno, nous avons décidé
de vous faire découvrir ce petit paradis.
Alors, on résume souvent Maurice à ses plages,
mais vous allez voir que l'île
a beaucoup plus à offrir.
Pour vous donner une petite idée
de la richesse des paysages et de la culture mauricienne,
je vous propose de rejoindre
Bruno sur place
et on commence par le district de Rivière Noire,
à l'ouest de l'île.
Oui Jamy, je viens d'arriver à Chamarel
et concrètement,
c'est connu pour notamment
ce qui est derrière moi actuellement.
Ça, c'est la Terre des Sept Couleurs
et ça porte carrément très bien son nom.
Parce que t'as de l'ocre, t'as du marron,
t'as du rouge, t'as du violacé.
C'est vraiment un bonheur pour la rétine.
Ici, je te promets,
c'est plus de 7500 mètres carrés
qui sont derrière moi,
qui sont colorés de cette façon.
Et d'ailleurs,
je me pose une question toute bête
est-ce que tu connais
l'origine de ces terres ?
On a du mal à l'imaginer,
mais il y a environ 8 millions d'années,
l'île Maurice était un volcan
en pleine activité.
C'est à cette époque
que d'immenses quantités de lave
sont sorties des entrailles de la terre
et de l'océan pour former cette île.
Oui, enfin Jamy je te rappelle que moi,
je suis à l'île Maurice actuellement,
donc de me dire que je suis
sur un ancien volcan en furie,
ça ne me rassure pas forcément.
Heureusement,
c'est beaucoup plus calme aujourd'hui.
D'ailleurs, qu'est ce qui s'est passé au final ici ?
A l'origine de ce volcan,
il y a ce que l'on appelle un point chaud,
au sens propre du terme.
La chaleur provient d'une zone située
à 2900 kilomètres sous nos pieds.
Des panaches s'élèvent dans ce qu'on
appelle le manteau terrestre.
Sous l'effet de la chaleur,
le magma, moins dense,
remonte vers la surface et s'accumule
sous la croûte terrestre.
Il finit par la percer comme un chalumeau.
La lave qui jaillit donne
alors naissance à un volcan.
C'est exactement ce qu'il s'est passé
il y a 8 millions d'années,
à la verticale de l'île
Maurice, en plein milieu de l'océan.
Ce point chaud est fixe,
mais la croûte terrestre qui le surplombe,
elle, se déplace.
Bah oui, vous avez sûrement entendu parler de
la tectonique des plaques.
Vous savez, ces plaques qui recouvrent
notre planète comme les pièces d'un puzzle
et qui bougent en permanence.
Au dessus de l'île Maurice,
la croûte terrestre se déplace
de quelques millimètres par an.
C'est ce qui explique
que sur des millions d'années,
ce même point chaud
a donné naissance à Rodrigues
avant de former l'île Maurice,
puis l'île de la Réunion,
en dessous de laquelle le point chaud
est encore situé aujourd'hui.
C'est aussi pourquoi le volcan
est éteint sur Maurice,
alors que le Piton de la Fournaise,
sur l'île de la Réunion, est encore très actif.
En résumé, l'île Maurice
est un ancien volcan sorti de l'océan.
Enfin, ce sont en réalité des milliers
d'éruptions successives qui ont formé l'île.
D'ailleurs, plusieurs cratères
sont encore visibles à Maurice.
L'un des plus connus
se situe ici, à Grand Bassin.
Oui, ce que vous voyez derrière moi,
c'est un immense cratère rempli d'eau
et d'ailleurs, c'est devenu
un lieu de pèlerinage pour les hindous.
Pourquoi Jamy ?
Je vais te répondre,
tout simplement parce que
une tradition raconte
que le dieu Shiva se baladait
avec sa femme Parvati
au dessus de notre belle planète.
Et devant la beauté de l'île Maurice,
il a laissé couler une larme
qui elle même est tombée dans ce cratère
et l'a donc remplie d'eau.
La cuisine  mauricienne est à l'image de l'île :
multiculturelle.
On y trouve des influences indiennes,
créoles, françaises
ou encore chinoises qui témoignent
de sa longue histoire coloniale.
L'île a été successivement occupée
par les Hollandais au XVIIᵉ siècle,
puis par les Français au XVIIIᵉ
et enfin les Anglais de 1810 à 1968,
année de l'indépendance
de la République de Maurice.
Cette histoire mouvementée a forgé
l'identité de ce pays qui est aujourd'hui
composé de nombreuses communautés, dont
la plus importante
est d'origine indienne
et ça se retrouve dans la cuisine.
Après l'abolition de l'esclavage en 1833,
le gouvernement britannique
décide d'engager des travailleurs
pour remplacer le départ des esclaves
dans les plantations de canne à sucre.
Ils viennent principalement
d'Inde, de Chine ou d'Afrique de l'Est.
Considérés comme des travailleurs libres,
ils passaient néanmoins 5 à 7 ans
à travailler gratuitement
pour rembourser les frais de voyage
avancés par leur employeur.
Jusqu'en 1920,
près de 500000 hommes et femmes
en provenance
d'Inde arrivèrent ainsi à Port-Louis.
C'est exactement ça.
Ces migrants,  ils arrivaient à un lieu
qui s'appelle l'Aapravasi Ghat
c'est un lieu qui est à Port-Louis,
la capitale de l'île, qui est juste derrière moi,
et c'est un lieu qui est vraiment
chargé d'histoire, évidemment,
qui est même classé au patrimoine
mondial de l'Unesco.
Et d'ailleurs, on peut le visiter,
donc n'hésitez pas à y aller.
Aujourd'hui, on estime que près
de 70% de la population mauricienne
est d'origine indienne.
Mais l'île compte aussi des Mauriciens
créoles, c'est à dire métisses,
et des Mauriciens d'origine chinoise
ou européenne.
Niveau langue, c'est la même chose.
Il y en a une vingtaine à Maurice.
Les plus parlées étant le créole
mauricien, le français et l'anglais.
Et il n'est pas rare
de trouver des habitants qui parlent
cinq ou six langues différentes.
Cette situation illustre évidemment
le passé de Maurice, qui se retrouve
dans la culture du pays
et notamment dans sa gastronomie.
C'est vrai qu'ici, c'est aussi
un voyage pour le palais
parce que t'as des influences créoles,
indiennes ou encore asiatiques.
En gros, c'est vraiment pas étonnant
que la gastronomie mauricienne
se soit un petit peu exportée partout autour du monde.
Et d'ailleurs, je suis au marché
de Port-Louis, là.
Ça envoie du lourd.
Toutes ces couleurs,
tous ces produits, ça donne envie.
Allez, je vais prendre une petite tasse
de thé pour finir le repas.
Ça tombe bien, le thé mauricien
est particulièrement réputé.
Je vous propose d'ailleurs
de rejoindre Bruno dans une plantation à Bois Chéri.
Oui, effectivement,
je suis bien à Bois Chéri,
qui est sur la route du thé
et concrètement ici,
il y a une usine qui existe depuis plus de
100 ans pour produire évidemment du thé.
On produit plus de 5000 tonnes par an
sur des centaines d'hectares.
On exporte d'ailleurs,
par exemple en France,
au marché de Rungis,
qui est le plus grand marché d'Europe.
Bref, il y a même un petit musée
pour les curieux.
Les Mauriciens évidemment y consomment
énormément de thé et d'ailleurs, n'hésite
pas à le goûter Jamy,
parce qu'il est particulièrement sympa ce thé.
Tu as raison, Bruno.
Il est très bon ce thé.
Et oui, à Maurice,
on peut déguster du thé local,
du thé qu'on peut même sucré
avec du sucre produit sur l'île.
Et ça, c'est très cool.
Et oui,
rien de tel que la production locale.
Et je crois que tu n'es pas seul
pour nous en parler, Bruno.
Bonjour à vous, je m'appelle Charognes
et je travaille au domaine de Bois Chéri.
Alors domaine de Bois Chéri,
qu'est-ce qu'on y produit ?
On y produit seulement le thé.
Comme vous voyez tout autour de nous,
c'est la plantation de thé pour les 250 hectares que nous avons.
Il y en a vraiment de partout.
Et le thé à l'île Maurice, c'est quelque chose de spécial ?
Quelque chose de réputé ?
Tout à fait.
Les Mauriciens aiment beaucoup le thé réputé.
C'est le thé à la vanille.
Le thé à la vanille, c'est plus les arômes
qu'on met plus dedans,
pour que les Mauriciens aiment le plus,
ici, sur l'île.
Et même quand on a des étrangers,
eux aussi aiment le thé à la vanille.
Parce que les Mauriciens, apparemment,
ils consomment beaucoup de thé, non ?
Tout à fait.
Du genre ?
Toi t'en bois beaucoup?
Oui, j'en bois deux tasses.
D'ailleurs Jamy,
dis-moi si toi tu veux tester le thé.
J'adore ce parfum de vanille.
Le thé,
tout comme la canne à sucre,
ne sont pas des cultures originaires de Maurice.
La canne à sucre a été introduite par
les Hollandais au milieu du XVIIᵉ siècle,
mais ce sont les Français
qui ont développé cette industrie
au cours du XVIIIᵉ siècle, en même temps
qu'ils ont introduit le thé.
Et la production du sucre
est intimement lié au destin de Maurice
et à son passé colonial.
Vous pouvez d'ailleurs en découvrir
l'histoire et les secrets de fabrication
dans le Musée de l'aventure du Sucre,
installé dans une ancienne usine sucrière
à Pamplemousses,
dans le nord ouest de l'île.
Encore totalement sauvage
avant l'arrivée des hommes,
l'Île a connu depuis le XVIIᵉ siècle
une forte déforestation,
en grande partie
pour développer les cultures.
Alors que la jungle dominait
le territoire,
les forêts n'occupent plus aujourd'hui
qu'un quart de la surface de l'île.
L'une des plus impressionnantes
se situe dans le parc national
des gorges de la rivière Noire,
dans le sud ouest de l'île.
Exactement Jamy !
Je viens d'arriver au coeur du parc
et regarde moi, après trois quarts d'heure
de randonnée sur quoi je tombe.
C'est immense je ne l'ai même pas en entier.
C'est la cascade 500 pieds.
Elle est vraiment magnifique
et je peux te dire qu'ici,
il y a beaucoup de choses à faire
entre le canyoning,
entre les 60 km de sentiers de randonnée
ou encore ça,
il y en a pour tout le monde.
Et d'ailleurs, je vais te laisser tout de suite
parce qu'apparemment,
il y a des oiseaux uniques au monde
que je peux observer ici.
Donc, je vais les chercher.
Le parc des Gorges de la rivière Noire
constitue la plus grande réserve
naturelle de Maurice.
Il s'étend sur plus de 67 kilomètres
carrés.
C'est le paradis des randonneurs,
mais aussi des amateurs d'oiseaux.
La forêt héberge en effet
une cinquantaine d'espèces.
Si vous allez à Maurice,
n'oubliez pas vos jumelles.
Avec un peu de chance,
vous pourrez observer la crécerelle
ou la perruche de Maurice,
deux espèces endémiques,
c'est à dire
qu'on ne trouve que sur l'île Maurice.
Ouais Jamy,
en parlant d'animal endémique,
j'en ai vu un sur les billets de banque
ou même sur les tampons de passeport.
Je parle du dodo.
J'aimerais bien savoir
ce qui lui est arrivé.
Ah ! Le dodo,
l'animal emblématique de Maurice.
Vous en trouverez partout, en peluche,
en bois, sur les tee shirt,
mais ne le cherchez pas en forêt,
il a malheureusement disparu de l'île
à la fin du XVIIᵉ siècle.
Il a été victime de la chasse
et des attaques d'animaux
introduits par l'homme, comme les rats,
les chiens et les chats.
Ce pigeon géant d'un mètre de haut
est devenu le symbole des extinctions
animales causées par l'homme.
Vous pouvez découvrir son histoire,
une reconstitution de l'oiseau
ainsi qu'un squelette complet au Musée
d'histoire naturelle de Port-Louis.
Pour terminer notre voyage à Maurice,
je vous propose maintenant
de prendre un peu de hauteur
et de retrouver Bruno dans les airs.
Enfin,
presque, à la pointe sud ouest de l'île.
Bon Jamy, je viens de rencontrer quelqu'un
qui s'appelle Bruno.
Ceci n'est pas une blague
et Bruno est Drone expert.
Il le met sur son t-shirt
tellement qu'il en est fier
et il me montre quelque chose
d'extraordinaire.
Bruno, tu peux expliquer ce qu'on voit là ?
Écoute on voit une cascade sous-marine.
J'ai jamais vu ça de ma vie, mais c'est quoi en fait ?
C'est une illusion d'optique un peu, non ?
C'est une très belle illusion d'optique de la nature.
Apparemment,
c'est du sable qui s'enfonce, etc.
Je pense que tu peux mieux l'expliquer que moi,
mais en tout cas, c'est extraordinaire sur le drone.
Je vais essayer, Bruno.
Effectivement, c'est très impressionnant.
Il s'agit bien d'une illusion d'optique.
Je vous explique, ce n'est pas de l'eau,
mais bien du sable qui s'écoule.
Ce déplacement est dû à un courant marin
qui pousse le sable
depuis la côte vers le large
en suivant la pente et en s'enfonçant
donc petit à petit,
le sable change de couleur
et ce dégradé progressif
donne l'illusion d'une cascade d'eau vive.
Autour, le site est magnifique,
notamment cette montagne qui domine l'océan.
C'est le Morne Brabant.
Elle s'élève à 555 mètres d'altitude
et selon les amateurs de marche,
son ascension constitue
l'une des plus belles randonnées de l'île.
Mais au delà de la balade,
le Morne Brabant
est l'un des symboles historiques de Maurice.
Il est classé au patrimoine mondial
de l'Unesco,
car ce site était un sanctuaire
pour les esclaves.
Au XVIIIᵉ siècle, jusqu'au début du XIXᵉ
nombreux sont ceux qui se sont réfugiés
dans sa forêt dense
ou dans les grottes creusées
sur ses flancs.
Aujourd'hui,
ce lieu est un emblème de la lutte
pour la liberté
et la résistance à l'esclavage.
Bon Jamy, après 2 heures de marche,
je quasiment arrivé en haut
et regarde moi cette vue,
elle est juste magnifique.
Wow !
C'est splendide,
mais faut pas avoir la peur du vide.
Bon Bruno, j'espère que mes explications
ne t'ont pas donné le vertige.
Merci beaucoup, Jamy,
pour ces beaux périples.
Moi, j'ai adoré te montrer
les plus beaux coins de l'île Maurice.
Il me reste plus qu'à te dire
à bientôt autour du monde
et surtout, n'oublie pas de voyager.
Peace !
T'inquiète pas, Bruno.
Ma valise est toujours prête.
Bon, j'espère que notre petit tour
à l'Ile Maurice vous a plu
et vous a permis d'apprécier la richesse
de ses paysages et de sa culture.
Avec Bruno, nous vous donnons rendez-vous
très vite pour une nouvelle carte postale.